il quitte régulièrement les barbots
saint-denis celles sur lesquelles on
cela est facile on boit un verre pour le
vol de ravine-blanche à saint-pierre
parole de riders ce goal c'est le spot
idéal pour s'exprimer en roller il faut
juste savoir se faire une place ambiance
aux heures de pointe avec donatien
ripoll un week-end comme les autres à
ravine blanche à saint pierre
tout notre temps là on vient de saint
louis donc de temps en temps on
recommence fait des week-ends entre
couette pour aller rouler ici pour faire
de la rampe qui changent que saint denis
c'est plutôt des skate park qui est
fondue street le streak qui consiste
plus à faire des sly sur des bacs
donc particularité de ce skatepark c'est
le seul le skatepark de lille qui
possède en vol donc un bol proprement
parler est une rampe qui est incrustée
dans le sol comme une piscine disons que
st-pierre grâce aux rentrées
les décollages on va dire sont
meilleures on peut ce qui nous permet de
mieux sauter ici de faire des rotations
dur 547 120 et le décollage ce qui est
un plus ici plutôt que les autres
ce qui est bien ici c'est que laurent
touret de la plage du soleil à une bonne
ambiance et où on va dire on peut slide
et surtout nous surtout ce qu'on voit en
fait jusqu'à même les barrières de
sécurité donc non la côte est c'est un
peu pour montrer montrer ce qu'on sait
faire
un skate park dans les trois disciplines
le ce que le skateboard le roller et
le bmx donc forcément les trois qu'ils
s'entendent pas forcément chacun on va
dire assez entre guillemets clans entre
copains on va dire qu'on respecte la
règle de chacun son tour à peu près où
on prévient son passage donc on lève la
main prévient être ça pour faire
attention puisque bien sûr pour
respecter les plus jeunes qui débutent
qui font pas forcément aussi attention
donc envahi parce qu'il peut y avoir des
tricheries des chutes très violente à
pleine vitesse
m ah ah
ça c'est bondé au niveau 2 des gens qui
circulent et qui regarde qui sortent des
supermarchés ou tout simplement des gens
qui pratiquent leur foi
tout à fait
qu'est ce que ce week-end
c'est les rendre ça change la vitesse et
des sceaux c'est plus ça va dire ce qui
impressionne dans le sport c'est moins
les slides bien sûr c'est toujours
toujours toujours très captivant et
intéressant surtout que le skatepark de
saint-pierre attire beaucoup plus de
demandes que au skatepark de livres
non